Mean it and I mean,
look at,
uh,
Gabby Giffords in Arizona.
I mean,
I,
I'm don't believe in voting,
but she had this tweet about like a,
she went and voted and I couldn't think of a better pro voting argument that she
kind of was like,
look,
you know,
you don't believe in voting.
Voting.
Yeah.
Um,
what does that mean?
I don't believe in voting.
What do you mean?
I don't think I don't do it.
I don't,
I'd never wrote an article about it for the Guardian.
Uh,
I just don't think it's legitimate voting democracy in Wa in any way.
Like the idea that I flick a switch and someone gets to talk to me for four
years,
talk for me for four years doesn't make any sense.
What do you think the alternative should be?
Freedom.
If I want to someone to speak for me,
I'll hire them.
And the idea that me and my neighbors have to be locked into some policy because
we're geographically close to each other.
His landline technology in a post cell phone world.
So how do you think things should be run PR you organize based on how,
who you want to align with on any given,
uh,
contexts.
Like I'm aligned with Macy's when it comes to my clothes and I'm aligned with
you when it comes to talking.
You don't have to have one guy speak for you for abortion and for,
uh,
the borders and for taxes.
I mean,
I don't believe in any of that stuff.
This is very old,
old model.
I agree that it's a very old model.
But the problem is we don't have any other one.
Sure we do because nine one or the other one,
99% of our interactions are voluntary and you come together with people as you
need to and then you go your separate ways and it's very,
very dynamic.
So this idea that you're stuck with this person because a lot of people like him
for four years and they speak for you,
it makes no sense to me.
It does not make sense,
but it's also we feel like we need some sort of a representation of us.
If you're going to have some sort of a summit with a guy like Putin,
sure.
Or someone Kim Jong Moon or whatever it is,
whoever it is,
someone needs to speak for us.
Sure.
Right,
and I mean in the sense that is a reaction,
but the point is I don't think vast majority of people in this country are not
have asked.
A lot of people say,
Trump's not my president.
He doesn't speak for me and they have a right to say that.
And the idea that just because someone was a contest,
therefore he's the boss of me.
What do you think about voting when it comes to legitimate concerns?
Like raising the speed limit,
reducing taxes,
doing this,
doing that,
like fixing roads,
like certain things that we need to get done.
I don't,
I don't do it.
I mean that makes more sense to me because it's a direct representation,
but even that shouldn't be up to majority rule.
I mean,
people who understand the dynamics of speed limits and cars should have informed
say rather than,
right.
But then there's influenced by the insurance companies,
and this is why low rates,
this is why things changed.
But she got lost.
But insurance companies are the ones who have the campaigns to force people to
vote one way or another.
It's going to be one,
right?
One side's gonna have much more like,
like marijuana laws,
you know,
and all these,
the tobacco and alcohol companies trying to make sure that marijuana is not
legal.
Uh,
and all these,
this propaganda that you have because they don't want competitors when you
rather have people be high than drunk.
Like if dad's coming home from work,
I'd rather he had a joint than a six pack.
I mean,
and yet historically,
just because alcohol has been popular,
that's what's legal.
It makes no sense.
No,
that doesn't mean drunk driving versus driving stoned.
Having one guy's going to slow the other ones.
You know what one's going to probably paranoid too,
and checking on every mirror.
Checking
cool.
Drive slower,
slow down Cuba together,
writing the lines,
right?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't think that the system that we have now is great,
but to just not participate at all.
Well,
I do participate.
Obviously,
if I'm a public figure and I'm talking right,
he's participating.
So just discourse yet to some extent.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't think the idea that you're flicking a switch means you're actually
making a difference.
I think eight,
you're doing something in secret.
Once every four years,
you're not actually participating.
That's something people like to tell themselves.
It's like getting a communion wafer.